我們來比賽一下
來
來加油加油加油
好可以可以可以
直接力竭
這是兩年前的我
這是現在的我
從我的InBody報告可以發現
我的肌肉這兩年掉了超過兩公斤
而這是一個年近40歲的人
很容易遇到的問題
你的肌肉逐年的下降
每年可能是
特別是在你的下肢
你的核心的肌肉流失越明顯
而因為你肌肉的流失
會造成你代謝下降
所以你吃的東西可能跟以前一樣
熱量也差不多
但你卻發現你的腰圍越來越粗
內臟脂肪越來越多
這都是因為肌肉流失之後
影響你代謝的一個後果
第三個身體變化是
30歲之後
你的睪固酮每年就會下降1%到2%
這會讓你開始變得沒有精神活力
增肌減脂變得非常困難
甚至你的血糖開始失控
這是年紀造成睪固酮影響的結果
當然身為一個醫師
不能眼睜睜看這些狀況持續惡化下去
而作為一個工作忙碌
又要顧小孩的二寶爸
只要透過居家的訓練方式
就能達到增肌的效果
來改善身體的狀況
不過特別提醒一下我們觀眾朋友
你本身有
還是建議到初日診所找醫生聊聊
點擊右上方按鈕
檢測男性賀爾蒙失衡的風險
檢測你身體還剩多少馬力
好話不多說
那我們現在就趕快出發到運動用品店
來安排我的居家增肌訓練課程囉
老實說啊
我也買過不少器材
像是壺鈴啊彈力帶
啞鈴都買過
可是練起來呢
效果就是不怎麼樣
所以我今天就來這裡請教運動專家
幫我規劃一套
大家好我是迪卡儂的運動專家
我們今天主要就是幫李醫師設計一個
就是專門for居家訓練的
一個肌肥大的一個訓練模式
就是所有全身的部位都可以訓練到
那我們可以採取的
一個原理是比較偏向是
就是我們盡量去拉長
我們的訓練的次數
或是組數
那可以有效達到一個
一樣肌肥大的一個效果
第一個的話
我們其實就是把雙手就是放在兩側
放在兩側之後呢
可以直接就是繞過你的身體
把它置於就是你的背部的上方這邊
然後讓這個彈力帶卡在
肩膀跟手的這個部位
第一個動作重點就是
很多人在做胸推的時候會忘記
就是說
欸他肩膀越來越聳
就練到的都是你的斜方肌
你的脖子就越來越痠
第二個動作重點是你的手肘
大概跟你的身體是成為大概45度
那我們就可以往前先試推看看
往前去做集中的動作
然後就可以稍微停留一下
然後回來之後可以慢慢的放
你要想像就是胸已經在發力
然後讓這個動作往前帶
不是說我手直接往前推
我們下一個的話會講到是
這個動作的重點是
就是握牢之後不要去遠離你的身體
這樣去貼近你的身體
我們的臀往後推的時候
同時這個壺鈴往下帶
重點要提醒大家就是
我們的脊椎的部分我們不要彎腰
也不要拱背
這時候會感覺到
我們的臀大肌跟我們的腿後側正在發力
起來的時候
也不用刻意的去推我們的髖
就是站直就可以了
然後(壺鈴)下降的部位
每個人活動度不一樣
所以你可以採取
你自己舒適的一個角度
我們接下來會做的是
首先我們需要一張椅子
然後我們就可以把我們的膝蓋
跟手就是放在側邊
動作重點是我們一樣手不要開
我們把手肘往斜後方去帶
然後還有一個很大需要留意的地方是
我們不要用甩的
很多人在做的時候會這樣
這其實是一個
那一樣就可以配我們的呼吸
上提的時候吐氣
然後下放的時候吸氣
我非常期待要開始60天的挑戰
把我失去的肌肉趕快再練回來
那我們就希望李醫師可以增肌成功
除了運動的訓練以外呢
營養補充也是非常重要的
所以你要增肌的話
好希望我接下來每天
可以吃到
如果整天總量吃的不夠
可能甚至會在睡前補充所謂的酪蛋白
來幫助我的肌肉的修復跟生長
那除了蛋白質以外我會吃肌酸
肌酸有助於我運動的表現
還有肌肉的合成
而除了蛋白質跟肌酸
別忘記碳水化合物
你千萬不要在無碳的時候
不吃澱粉的時候來做運動
這樣不只是運動表現會很差
對於你的肌肉的肥大都是沒有幫助的
那除了運動跟營養以外呢
我中間也會規劃一系列的
一邊練一邊吃
還有邊觀察身體的變化
有沒有在正確增肌的軌道上
總結這次計畫的三大重點
話不多說
那主要還是心態上跟生理上的消耗
就是整天這樣工作下來啊
其實體力已經沒有了
你可能回到家
心理上非常的耗竭
就會變成一種
你就完全沒有動力想要去做運動
所以我覺得心理上的那種耗竭
這幾週下來還需要趕快去調適的地方
但是只要有時間我會去做
就像我在診間也常跟我們客人講
你的飲食計畫
不可能一個禮拜七天
每一餐都做到非常非常理想
那至少你慢慢的做到5成以上
7成以上到8成
那到8成的話
效果其實就慢慢出來
那我自己也發現
其實這樣很零碎的時間
每天只要有訓練
哪怕只是一組兩組三組
這樣累加起來
其實效果比我想像中好滿多的
因為我是比較像是
專注在每個肌群的訓練
並沒有側重哪一部分
但是每個地方的感受度都差滿多的
像是引體向上好了
我一剛裝上去的時候
我好像只拉了一下還兩下
我就拉不上去了
可是我現在一次做下來
我可以寬握窄握反手
一次都可以做個五六下沒有問題
所以我覺得體感上的進步
也是非常棒的
那如果提到這一套訓練
有沒有什麼比較辛苦的地方
不是我們想像到
時間或是空間上的限制
反而是我要怎麼讓身體能夠快速的恢復
比如說我睡前只要做一些
或者比較簡單
我覺得那一天的睡眠品質
就會特別的好
當睡眠品質特別好的時候
我隔天要再去訓練的時候
我覺得感覺整個身體修復狀況
也特別好滿多的
其實我自己覺得飲食上
並沒有太多被剝奪
或是被限制的感覺
因為我本來的飲食
就還是有一套自己的一些原則在
如果真的有挑戰的話
其實是早餐跟午餐
我一早上通常都是要很快就去趕高鐵
要去高雄上班
然後一到診所就開始要進入看診狀態
完全沒有時間可以停下來吃東西
那有時候一中午的時間
可能看診delay
我也沒有太長時間
可以好好的坐下來吃東西
所以早餐跟午餐的營養
我覺得對我來說是滿大挑戰
補給的部分
不管是在力量的恢復
或身體的修復的速度上
我覺得感受都差滿多的
嗨大家好
我們現在來到了健身工廠
因為我在健身增肌這段時間
開始遇到點心態還有身體上的瓶頸
所以我們特別請了我們
初日減重非常成功
健康的案例霸軒來幫我一把
李醫師好久不見
那霸軒我想問一下
你自己好像也是在
健身工廠的台南中華廠健身
對對對我健身非常久
一直以來都在健身工廠
不過你好像還自己打造了一個
非常完整的一個Home gym
你最推薦Home gym要怎麼樣去建造
如果以打造Home gym來講的話
必要的一定是史密斯機
就是那個史密斯機
就是它有龍門架嘛對不對
然後同時又有滑輪
對
又可以做keepboard
就是它是一個本體
那本體你可以做很多的
延伸跟附加運動
啊如果你真的空間不允許
最基本的就是臥推椅加啞鈴
不要小看啞鈴
啞鈴加一組臥推椅
那動作上你最推什麼
我自己最喜歡的當然就是
自由槓的臥推
背部的話
其實我最喜歡的T-bar
但是這個我家裡沒有
所以我一定要到健身工廠
我在家裡面的話
第一個一定做啞鈴划船
我反而滿推薦新手
盡量做單邊動作
單邊動作 -對對對
因為我以前的話
剛開始練的時候我喜歡用槓鈴的划船
但是我後來發現
我做單臂划船的時候更有感
腿的話我原本是自由槓的深蹲
但是由於我最近椎間盤突出
所以我現在目前都改保加利亞分腿蹲
你自己也練了2年欸
告訴大家你怎麼樣撐過來的
這就是Home gym的重要性啊
我每天早上起來第一件事就是
走到Home gym
我會先走有氧啊
其實已經把訓練
融入到你的生活裡面去
我覺得是每次健身完之後都超爽的
就是以前的話是
我會有空閒的時間
我會拿來玩手機
但是我後來玩遊戲
玩之後你會有一種空虛感
你也知道現代都市人
在這種快節奏生活中
就是會覺得說
為什麼這兩個時間不拿來充實自己
所以我每次在我工作很累很累的時候
超級不想去運動
但是最後你還是咬著牙去了
然後練完的那一刻你就覺得說
那個一整個
就腦內啡讓你覺得很快樂
對我覺得說
沒錯而且我覺得這個
也是跟多巴胺有點關係
所以運動完通常有些人
沒辦法好好的睡覺
是
就是內啡肽分泌的不錯
那我們講如果另外一個是
會讓你長時間下來更有驅動力
想要去做這件事情
我覺得這也是運動到後期
你身體會自然而然
產生一個很好的反應
就一個正循環
你就不會想說我要靠垃圾食物
或是一些滑手機去
達到讓你身體放鬆的效果
那李醫師
我聽說你最近在實施這個
那你目前你覺得最有感的
在家裡面的自主訓練是什麼
目前我用主要是彈力帶跟啞鈴為主
彈力帶
哇你是用好幾條是不是
你是用50條是不是
同一條而已啦
wwwwww
用彈力帶是比較像是夾胸
比較像飛鳥的感覺
恩
這是彈力帶胸可以做的訓練
那第二個是啞鈴
我會拿來做划船
啞鈴划船我覺得那個
目前是在這幾個動作
我覺得CP值比較高
那這個就是我們剛才提到
就是如果你在家裡想做引體向上
那可能你本身體重比較重
就用彈力帶做輔助
你只要很簡單把它掛上去
然後穿的時候腳放在這裡
你就會覺得好像有人在下面推你的感覺
有一個push的感覺 -對
快跟著李醫師在家找回理想體態
點擊右上方按鈕
測出你的居家運動等級
我想問一下霸軒啊
練了2年多的時間
你到哪一個時間點開始覺得
自己的狀態已經完全不一樣
其實我練到1年的時候
我覺得我的重量
好像不是一般人可以拉的重量
有比一般沒有健身的人壯一點
那如果講外表的話
就是因為體重其實掉滿多的嘛
是
那後面你這樣整個瘦下來之後
你沒有覺得別人看你的眼光
有沒有什麼落差啊
我覺得瘦下來之後
整體比例會好看一點點
所以以前我不止一次被粉絲認出來
就說你本人好矮喔
還有你本人看起來好胖喔
但是我真的健身之後
喔霸軒你本人有壯欸
然後就覺得
減重的當下還是真的要配合運動
減掉得不是只有體重啊
你還是要變得更健康才對
就讓自己變得更好
其實我覺得是一個很自信的來源
另一半也會很有自信
給你看看我老公長什麼樣子
那最後一題就是
兩年多下來
你覺得哪個是影響你最大
其實我覺得
訓練的這兩年
我肌肉量是一直在提升的 -對
但是肌肉量提升其實對我的心態
我頂多就是說
欸我很喜歡練練舉重
然後我覺得有力量在提升
我很開心
但是真的讓我又昇華到下個階段的時候
就是我找到李唐越醫師的時候
那時候我的體重開始有計劃性
因為以前我
只是專項於重量訓練
或者一直想要增加身體的重量
跟肌肉的狀態 -對
但是有計劃性的
目標性的減脂下來的時候
看著自己的目標一直下降
喔那個開心的感覺
而且你以前練得很壯
大家就說你越來越胖
你真的變瘦的時候
他們不會說你變瘦
他們會說發現你變壯了
反而是你的體脂在下降
或脂肪在減少
別人才會覺得你壯
所以真的開心的時候是瘦下來的時候
不錯這個分享還滿重要的
那我們是不是應該要小考一下
沒問題
我們我們來比賽一下
來
wwwwwwwwwww
加油
來加油加油加油
啊
好可以可以可以
直接力竭
再來
來
榨乾他再一下
點到胸了
應該還可以啊
哇好爽喔
結果跟我想的一樣
沒有沒有
而且霸軒後來應該還可以再繼續
沒有沒有我只能說我們兩流派不一樣
就是我是注重那個重量的
那個李醫師的話是注重感受度
其實我覺得健身這一塊
重量一直都是其次
最重要是什麼
然後第二點是我們
你只要這兩點都有達到
那其實我就覺得足夠了
感謝今天霸軒特別來台中
我們謝謝李醫師
好謝謝霸軒
今天是增肌計畫第50天
那我現在打的這是一個
高濃度的一個抗氧化的營養點滴
那為什麼打這個點滴呢
因為其實我們在訓練的過程中
不管是你做重訓或是做高強度的運動
其實你身體的耗氧量
那這個過程中
你的能量系統或者去燃燒這個能量
就會產生很多的所謂的自由基
那同時你在重訓的時候
你的肌肉其實會有一些
維細的纖維的撕裂
那這些反應短暫的讓身體有點壓力
其實是OK的
因為這種殺不死你的壓力
就讓你變得更強壯
可是如果你平常又工作忙碌啊
睡眠沒那麼好
那吃東西可能有一兩天
飲食也不是那麼的均衡
沒辦法攝取到足夠的營養素
那身體就很容易累積
那這就很會造成你身體的疲勞
恢復的狀況比較差
甚至容易有延遲性的酸痛
再加上壓力的皮質醇如果是高的話
你的增肌的效果就會打折扣
所以我通常都會安排在訓練的隔天
來做這個點滴的施打
那我覺得可以去讓大量的這些營養素
進到我身體裡面
去達到平衡壓力和改善這個疲勞
所以我覺得點滴對我來說
其實滿有幫助的
就算你沒有要增肌好了
其實在減重過程中
不要讓身體那麼容易產生發炎的狀態
壓力荷爾蒙可以比較緩解下來
其實對減重也都很有幫助
所以滿推薦
不管是你要增肌減重
或是讓身體更健康的朋友
都可以來安排這個點滴的施打
我有再跟迪卡儂Charlie再討論了一下
那他有幫我設計了一個叫
那我覺得這個動作CP值非常的高
因為第一個在家裡就可以做嘛
第二個是
它不需要任何大重量的器材
著重的是在於你動作的穩定
跟你的感受度
它對於臀腿的肌肉刺激都非常的好
那這也是我們在重訓的時候要注意的
如果你用一樣的動作
一樣的重量去訓練的時候
你的肌肉就不會再生長
你要給他一點新的刺激
再去輕微的去破壞它
刺激它一下它就會變得更強壯
再過10天就是我們
我也非常期待這個結果的發表
最近呢我用了我們診所的
InBody的體組成量測
所以呢它也能夠獲得更多身體的資訊
包括像是全身相位角
而全身相位角就反應出我們
一般來說
正常的相位角應該位於
而男生因為細胞內水比較高
肌肉強度比較高
所以比較高一點
而至於我測出來的數據
整體來說也不算太差
好各位我們現在已經來到
那今天就要來成果發表
來看一下我的InBody
兩個月下來是怎樣的變化
那我們先看一開始的時候量呢
我的體脂率是18.2%
然後體重是73.2公斤
那這個體脂率算是來到我
近期的新高點
我以前的體脂率大概就是14、15%附近
第一次量的肌肉量是33.7公斤
也算是近期肌肉量的低點
那平常的肌肉量大概就是35、36附近
經過一個月的訓練
跟身體的調整之後呢
其實體脂降滿多的喔
體脂率從18.2%降到15.8%
體脂肪重量從13.3降到11.6公斤
那這時候肌肉的變化也還不錯
肌肉從33.7公斤長到了35公斤
這第一個月的狀況
我個人還是滿滿意的
因為就是一個滿不錯的一個增肌
同時又有減脂的狀況
讓我們來看一下60天之後
結果體重來到76.1公斤
算是我減重之後人生的新高啊
不過體脂率不錯喔
已經來到14.4%
表示我的脂肪沒有增加
而肌肉量呢
有量到37公斤
所以從原本的33.7
到60天之後已經達到37公斤
所以我在這邊宣佈
這個60天的增肌計畫呢
我接下來會讓自己變得更強壯
而且下個月呢
我也會去追蹤我在這個計畫初期
量測的睪固酮的數值
看它變化如何
當然如果你有增肌減脂的困擾
都歡迎來初日診所找我聊聊
我會幫你擬定你
喜歡我的頻道呢
記得訂閱按讚分享
並且開啟小鈴鐺
就可以獲取更多健康知識喔
我們下期再見啦
掰掰